hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game uh from the 23rd
european team championship that uh will
basically shows us alireza's a run to
the top of the uh raiding mountain uh
he's continuing to uh
get these uh victories from seemingly
completely drawn positions and that's
something that has often been said of
magnus uh they said that magnus will win
like maybe six or seven out of ten drawn
end games and uh
there are very few players who could uh
do do something like this uh against uh
strong competition uh so this game uh
perfectly illustrates uh the difference
between a grand master and and uh sort
of a super grandmaster even though
that's not
a real title but um you know if you're
let's say between 25 and 2600 that is
much much different than if you are 2700
or or above as you'll see in this game
so let's see what happens alersa has the
white pieces and he opens with e4
we have c5 he's playing against the
greek grand master dimitrios matarovas
master vasilis uh board one uh for the
greek team uh we have knight to f3 e6
sorry about that uh and uh uh all it is
of course strikes in the center with d4
uh we have captures captures knight to
c6 and the knight to c3 now so this is
the taimano variation of the sicilian
and queen c7 the bastrop of the
variation we've seen this many times uh
we have bishop to e2 by alireza and now
a6 taking away the b5 square from uh
white uh white's pieces you do not want
to allow some knight to b5 move to
dislodge the queen from c7 and here
usually white will just castle bishop to
e3 is also a playable move f4 is a very
nice move but the move that alireza
plays is a very rare one
and it's only been played a handful of
times so knight captures on c6 is the
move b captures uh in the now queen to
uh the idea between uh behind this weird
line is that alireza wants to play queen
d3 queen g3 trade off the queens uh and
uh just go straight for the end game
hopefully getting uh after the black
queen captures on g3 getting a nice uh
semi-open h file for his rook so let's
see what happens here so it's still a
known position for example in 2019 in
gran chester in uh
croatia in the blitz tournament
alexander grieschuk had this position
against the yaniponyshi where d5 was
played that game ended in a draw but
here we have knight to f6 and now uh
there is one game where bishop to d2 was
played but alireza goes for his plan
queen to g3
and it is now as of move 9 that we have
a completely new game
so let's see how uh black continues
black says all right i'm
perfectly uh fine with trading queens
here uh we have queen captures h
captures and now d5 uh of course you do
not want to despawn remaining backwards
on d7 maybe if white gets e5 and could
be very unpleasant so this definitely
makes sense and black can be very happy
with his position now it is a traits on
d5 we have captures captures and now
bishop to f4 so nicely continuing
development preparing to castle
queenside and black plays bishop to b4
if he can capture and see three
messiapal it is a spawn structure here
on the queen side could be very good for
him then alireza will have three pawn
islands where black only will have two
uh and here bishop to e5 now the bishop
guards the knight and this is now a very
strong piece we have king to e7 black
says no need to castle here we just want
to get our rook into the game but for
the moment you can't really move this
rook because if you move it we're just
to capture the knight
and then pick up the the pawn on h7 so
here we have g4 and black goes bishop to
b7 continuing development the bishop is
very nicely placed on this long diagonal
and a3 now all it is i would be very
happy now if bishop captures on c3 is
played then he would be the one with the
bishop player so bishop backed the d6
offering a trade of bishops here and
alireza grabs it with bishop captures
king captures and now g5 grabbing more
space and dislodging this knight
we have knight to d7 and now comes queen
side castles and uh okay it's a pretty
equal-ish position but uh you know as
they say of equal-ish positions it's
only equally if you play uh the absolute
best move uh at uh uh you know at every
move so here black plays h6 he he wants
to get his work into the game somehow
but this uh h7 uh weakness will always
be here so he starts with h6
which uh you know
alleviates the pressure a little bit but
the downside of it is that he's left
with three pawn islands so here i'll it
is a capture so we have rook captures
rook captures an h6 g captures on h6 and
now uh g3 it's a very important move you
do not want this g2 pawn being a target
here so g3 is uh
very nicely played and also if the rook
comes to g8 you don't have to worry
about rook doing any damage along the g
file black grabs more space here he
plays f5 e5 is coming next and now uh
alireza has to figure out how to
uh how to get his work into the game now
rook to h1 again this would wouldn't
really be all that impressive because d4
then attacks the knight and the the rook
so you know not the greatest of most you
don't lose anything because rook d1 pins
the pawn but then e5 you only
you know you only help a black develop
so instead we have rook to d4 now
already has some ideas of rook to h for
going after the h6 pawn but also rook
the b for going after the bishop on b7
so
definitely the rook gains more activity
we have knight to f6 and now not going
for rook h4 right away first rook the b4
attacking the bishop king to c7
defending the bishop and only now rook
to h4 we go after the h6 spawn and black
defends it with rook to h8 and it
doesn't seem like white has all that
much here we have f3 uh it's a very nice
move again the
the pawn is nicely protected so you
don't have to worry about d4 at any
point and also you take away these
squares from the from the knight on f6
with e5
and here you can see how black is
controlling a lot of squares here and
someone said um
i was checking out the live coverage at
this point uh someone said that uh if
ali had this position with black
everyone would be saying like oh yeah
black is much better here look at all
the all the space that he's controlling
but as alireza is white here
they weren't really sure of how how
impressive black's position was
but uh
it is very nice so here alireza uh goes
knight the
d4 is coming so now you do not want this
to come with tempo but also you want to
play knight to c5 this will attack the
bishop it will add more pressure to the
pawn on a6 and also you will have this
e6 square maybe available for your
knight could also come in very handy so
a5 and not allowing this pawn to be a
target on a6 and now knight to c5
attacking the bishop and the bishop to
c6 now of course you do not want to give
up this strong bishop uh we have f4 by
algereza now trying to trade off
some pawns here and also you do not want
black to have this massive pressure in
the center so you want black either to
capture or to advance the pawn or you
will capture on e5 if black doesn't
capture so black advances the pawn this
is probably the best
but now what you've done is that yes you
you have a pass pawn but also uh alireza
won the d4 square for his knight so he
he goes for it knights to be three uh
attacks the pawn on a5 and also prepares
to shift the knight to d4 so king b6
activating the king a little bit more
defending the pawn and now knight to d4
again putting pressure on the bishop
here and on the f5 pawn and now here we
have bishop to d7 now this bishop will
now be nicely controlling the knight on
d4 uh but the f5 pawn will be will be a
a weakness for for for quite some time
so here we have bishop to h5 and this is
where black really has to
think about what what to do here the
bishop obviously wants to come to f7 and
put more pressure on this spawn and it's
not going to be easy to defend you
always have to be careful if some like
king here then you can maybe play knight
b3 check then the a5 bone becomes weak
so a lot of weaknesses in black's camp
and uh do you capture the bishop or do
you allow bishop to f7 now also bishop
to g6 might be an idea so uh here black
played rook to g8 black said all right
you capture what you want i'm gonna
capture on g3 and then my rook and my
pass pawn
should be enough to at least secure a
draw if not more however capturing the
bishop was also very nice for example if
knight captures an h5 rook captures
there's this very tricky move king the
c5 now the point here is that you're
attacking the knight and now for example
if knight captures an f5 you capture
here and after rook captures you play
rook g8 and now you will win this spawn
so we would see some like rook h5 going
after the h6 pawn we would see captures
captures and now for example a4 and
black is down upon but with the king
being so active with the rook being so
active with the past pawn being so close
to promotion uh we would have to say
that black black should be better here
but instead okay we we have rook to g8
going after the g3 pawn and now bishop
to f7 uh but now it's a little bit
different now bishop to f7 comes with
tempo the rook is attacked and you don't
have time for king to c5 and also you do
not have time to grab the pawn here if
you grab the pawn just rook captures on
h6 and how are you saving this knight
the knight and king are on the same
on the same file if you play king c5
attack the knight hoping to trade just
knight b3 check and we're going to pick
up the knight
on the next move so instead rook the g7
attacking the bishop and now bishop to
e6 yeah now we're putting pressure on
this bishop but what we're really doing
is going after the f5 pawn that's the uh
real weakness in black's position the
the backwards uh f5 pawn uh or rather
the the base of the pawn chain so bishop
captures an e6 we have not knight
captures an e6 but a nice vision to a
rook captures an h6 and now look at
these pieces on the sixth rank uh
aligned with with the black king so what
do you do here there's only one good
move for black we have to play bishop to
d7 the bishop here is very useful
controlling the knight on d4 and we have
to give back the piece this way rook
captures an f6 with check king to c5 and
now again we don't want to capture here
if we if we capture then we just trade
everything captures captures captures
and captures and we already said that
black should not have any problems here
even though he's down upon his position
is extremely active so instead after
king c5 alireza goes knight b3 check now
puts pressure on the a5 pawn as well
and how do you play this well
if you try to defend the pawn with king
to b5 the problem is there's this a4
move and now you can't capture this
if you capture knight c5 check picks up
the bishop so after this a for check you
would have to move the king let's say
king c4 now we're gonna capture on a5
with check and after king before even
knight to c6 with the check but now this
is much different captures capture so
we're going to play king captures on a4
and now rook d6 and you can see that
after let's say recaptures and g3 rook
captures on d5 uh you are much much
better here you cannot to defend the f5
pawn and the king will uh has no
problems of stopping the the e3 pawn the
black king is so far away from the
action uh this should be winning for
white
so instead after knight the b3 check
king the c4 right away was played uh and
now alireza grabs the a5 pawn with check
so knight captures on a5 king to d4 and
now rook to d6 and again uh we have a
position where black has to really
really
appreciate what he has and you know not
cling to what uh what he might have and
here uh of course uh
you're putting pressure on the bishop
you're putting pressure on this spawn
and uh it's not easy for for black to
figure this out but there is a move and
moving the e3 really allows black to you
know try and create something you give
up the d5 pawn and you play king f2 and
now you're threatening e3 e2 and e1 and
it would be very difficult for for white
to stop this you would have to play
knight to b3 and then after e3 knight to
c5 uh and now the point is that e2
doesn't work if you play e2 we just play
knights to d3 check and now we cover the
d1 square with the knight and now after
the king moves of course rook to e5
stops promotion and now we just enjoy
our past pawns this would be winning for
white so after knight to c5 what you
would have to do is just move the bishop
for example bishop to b5 and now the
game continues let's say rook e5 we're
going to play rook captures on g3 and
black has excellent chances here uh even
though he's down two pawns but it's uh
really you know a crazy crazy position
uh so this is what black should have
gone for this king the e3 is just uh
definitely the way to go however black
played bishop to b5 first uh he wants to
prepare it but now we have rook to b6
attacking the bishop and now bishop back
to e8 again
bishop to f1 to guard the e2 square
definitely has uh
uh has its uh you know upsides for
example king d2 we're going to play e3
check and after king to e1 uh we have to
play bishop to c4 unfortunately uh the
spawn to e2 move doesn't really do all
that much because how are you ever
getting this bishop back into the game
uh
there's not much
you can do here the rook can always come
to e6 you're not going to be able to
bring the black king any closer
so what you would have to do after king
e1 is something like bishop to c4 then
all it is i would probably trade and
then we get this position where you know
it's it's pretty crazy but uh you know
one would have to prefer black here but
okay now after this rook to b6 bishop to
f1 was not played uh we have bishop to
e8 and now alireza has uh you know a lot
more squares to operate with king the d2
was played with e3 with czech king the
e1 and now king the e4 and this is a
beautiful move by black black is saying
here that okay you can give rook to e6
check and pick up my bishop but what
what is black really doing all it is i
played rook to e6 check we have king to
f3 and now you have this position where
you know you might think okay we just
blundered a piece but uh maybe you know
maybe we haven't uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the only
winning move for alireza while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not capturing
the bishop that would be uh you know
just losing uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the move is
knight to b3 that's the good stuff we
have to be ready to deliver knights to d
for check and uh you know just uh win
the e2 square for our king that's the
way
to win this position the problem with
capturing the bishop is just rook h7 and
how are you defending against checkmate
you can see that the pawn and king are
covering all of these squares there's no
escape here you would have to give up
the rook and then okay this is just a
winning endgame
for black so alireza of course played
knight to b3 now he's ready to deliver
this now rook to h7 does nothing we're
just going to deliver knight to d4 check
and after the king moves just rook
captures an e3 with check and that's it
we have a winning position king f4 we're
going to play rook captures on e8 black
loses a piece and there's no
compensation here so instead after
knight to b3 we have bishop to g6 and
now comes knight to d for check okay the
f5 pawn is protected but it doesn't
really matter king captures on g3 rook
captures an e3 with check king captures
on f4 and now uh alireza again has to
figure out uh can he trade rooks for
example knight to the e6 czech king
captures the knight captures here not
really f4 is extremely strong and it
wins the game
for black because you have to you know
play f3 f2 check and the bishop can
easily kick the king away from the f1
square you know white might even get
checkmated here
so already just plays king f2 he defends
his own rook now is threatening knight
to the e6 check so bishop to f7 and now
knight to e2 with check king g5
rook to g3 with check king to f6 and
here alireza just trades rooks we have
rook captures king captures and king to
e3 and he was in this position on move
50 that dimitrios master vasilis
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the position is
completely winning for white and i will
just show you a couple of quick moves
just to show you how completely hopeless
the position is for black for example
king f6 king d4
we can play king g5 try to get our king
into the game for example king e5
doesn't really matter what you play the
point is that the king and the knight
control for example these two squares
not that one and there's no way for
black to make progress here if king g4
we can just play a4 we start pushing our
pawn he has black can put the bishop
somewhere to maybe help out with uh
the defense of the e8 square but we
don't care we just push b4 and after
black wastes some moves we're going to
play a7 for example bishop back bishop
to b5 bishop b7 b6 bishop to a8 and now
we bring the knight into the game now it
doesn't matter what you play for example
d4 if we capture then we lose the knight
but just knight e6 and after bishop b7
we're gonna play knight to c5 win the b7
square bishop here pawn here and that's
it like there's absolutely nothing uh
black can even try here even though he's
down only one pawn but there is zero
counter play here uh so yeah another
impressive victory for alireza and you
can see that there were a couple of
moments where black could have uh played
better but it required some really
really shoot maneuvering he had to give
up at least one point
for a lot of activity and then he would
have fighting chances he he would never
be like winning or anything but he would
definitely have fighting chances and
that's what you have to find
at um you know to play a a against uh
alireza but uh
you know he he tried to
hold on to everything and it just didn't
work out so very impressive and uh you
know just from an uh from an equal
endgame another victory for alireza
ferrugia and
yeah he seems to be winning a lot of
these uh you know completely drawn end
games but like i said that the end games
are completely drawn if both sides play
the absolute best moves which is almost
never the case and what does this mean
for
uh for the standings well just uh for
you to see here uh these are alireza's
last six games you can see that he uh
got five and a half out of six points uh
only even charge of croatia got a
drawing in the second round all the
other games alireza won and this puts
him uh to a rating performance of over 3
000 now that's a lot for for any player
to achieve and uh regarding the
standings as i know you guys are always
interested in this uh here are the
standings so you can see all it is are
firmly in third place 27 96.3 uh you
know uh very very close to dinglier and
2.7 points away and there are three more
rounds in this tournament so if alereza
continues this onslaught he will
overtake ding and it will only be
carlson left to dethrone uh but uh you
know that's not gonna happen anytime
soon because even if uh for example
magnus loses all the games to nipple in
the world championship match now in
november uh that's just going to mean
that nipple will become the you know
maybe highest rated player in the world
uh
instead of magnus so whatever happens in
that match it doesn't really uh matter
all that much for um
for alireza's placement uh in the in the
standings
uh but yeah uh all in all uh very
impressive uh end game uh really a
really nice line that alireza has chosen
here this that um garish chose against
nepo this queen to d3 followed by queen
to g3 you know it's uh
it doesn't give you much but it uh you
know gives you an interesting game where
black will have to think and there there
you know
isn't all that much background on this
so that's how he decided to to approach
this so just a nice equal position and
then we grind sort of like uh our good
friend bobby fisher would do
but yeah that's the game once again hope
you guys uh enjoyed it uh i would like
to wish a very happy birthday to zuza i
hope you had a great today and that
you've spent it with lots of friends and
family and of course chess
and i would like to thank michael
kennedy constantinos
rod hill and tudor sharp for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day the world
chess championship starts in some six
days
see you soon